WAI CHEE DIMOCK: So
just want to go back very
briefly to Hemingway's letter
to John Dos Passos just to
remind us what we are up
against, this claim on
Hemingway's part.
"A Mrs. George Kauffman
is here.
And she claims they want to cut
it all out-- the Indian
Camp story.
Cut the In Our Time chapters.
Jesus, I feel all shot
to hell about it.
Of course they can't do it
because the stuff is so tight
and hard and everything hangs
on everything else." So this
is the very recognizable
posture on the part of
Hemingway that everything is
tight and hard and everything
hangs on everything else.
But giving the publication
history of the various
chapters, and also the stories
published separately, whether
or not there is in fact an
organic unity among them.
That's the big question.
And last time we tried
to give Hemingway the
benefit of the doubt.
And we read the end of chapters
and the stories as if
they were indeed organically
integral to one another.
So today we'll try some
other combinations.
But I found this picture of
Hemingway and Dos Passos.
So you know Hemingway is to the
far right and that's Dos
Passos to the far left.
And I always love this.
And they actually both
wrote about war.
Dos Passos has a novel called
Three Soldiers.
Very, very great novel
about war as well.
So you can see that they
have a lot in common.
And here's another important
letter to Edmund Wilson.
This is slightly earlier.
"Finished the book of 14 stories
with a chapter in our
time between each...
to give the picture of
the whole between
examining it in detail.
Like looking with your eyes at
something, say a passing
coastline, and then looking
at it with 15x binoculars.
Or rather, maybe, looking at
it and then going in and
living in it--
and then coming out and
looking at it again...
it has a pretty good unity."
So once again, that
all-important word for
Hemingway, pretty good unity.
And that's a very
strong claim.
It's not really pretty
good, it's damn good.
But in any case, what's new
about this description is the
idea of zooming in and
zooming out, right?
So this is very much
the approach
that we've been taking.
And we've been thinking
of it in terms of
micro and macro, right?
So this, the first set
the terms that
we started out with.
And today I'd like to add a few
more terms that line up in
a similar way.
Obviously, not the same.
But they're kind of
interrelated.
So micro, macro obviously, up
close, from a distance.
Before and after.
And that's especially important
when a soldier is
coming back home.
What happened during the war.
What happened after the war.
And going along with that
intensity of the experience
when you're in the war.
And as we know from the story
"Soldier's Home," the
staleness of it when
you come back.
And then another pair of terms
very important to our class,
actually, is tragedy
and comedy.
Since this is a writing class,
I also want to stop for just
one minute and talk about this
as a kind of a useful analytic
and organizational structure
to use in your papers.
So start out with one pair of
analytic terms and then try
out the various variations
of that term in the
course of the paper.
And that will give you a
really tight structure.
That's what Hemingway wants.
So I'll explain this more, but
just keep this in your mind.
Think of your papers as theme
and variation, you inventing
different terms that would
allow for that theme and
variation structure.
So I'll talk more about
the substantive
implication of that.
But for now, I think that this
is really what Hemingway
himself is doing.
Because he's such a great
writer, he's a
good example to us.
So anyway, today we'll
be looking at
four possible clusters.
I want to emphasize that.
These are just conjectural
clusters.
We can test them.
The first one is chapter seven
and "Soldier's Home." And then
we'll be looking at chapter
nine and "Mr. and Mrs.
Elliot." Hilarious story.
Chapter ten and "Cat in the
Rain." And then chapter twelve
and "Big Two-Hearted
River: Part II."
So first chapter seven.
Once again, we're back in
wartime Europe, the
experience of combat.
"While the bombardment was
knocking the trench to pieces
at Fossalta, he laid very flat
and sweated and prayed oh
Jesus Christ get
me our of here.
Dear Jesus please get me out.
Jesus, please, please,
please, Christ...
The shelling moved further
up the line.
We went to work on the trench
and in the morning the sun
came up and the day was
hot and muggy and
cheerful and quiet.
The next night back at Mestre
he did not tell the girl he
went upstairs with at the
Villa Rossa about Jesus.
And he never told anybody."
So this is the classic dynamics
of before and after,
and intensity of the experience
when you're in the
thick of the battle, and the
sense that you really have
lost it all once that experience
is behind you.
So what Hemingway is exploring
here, and that he would we'll
see here also explore at great
length in "Soldier's Home" is
the intransitive relation
of emotions across time.
It's a terrible thing.
We think so much about the
question of sustainability.
It's important for things to
be sustainable across time.
It seems that Hemingway is
saying that, basically,
intense emotions are not
sustainable across time.
And we'll see this in a big way,
actually, in Faulkner in
The Sound and the Fury in
the Quentin section.
Even when we're devastated by
something, whether or not that
sense of devastation will be
with us, even a short moment
afterwards.
So it seems that when he is
fearing, in this kind of
mortal fear, for his
life, Jesus.
And that's really kind of
a name for something.
It's not necessarily Jesus.
Although in this case it
actually is Jesus.
But Jesus could also be a
shorthand for something that
we really want just to invoke.
And it's very much a presence
for us at that moment.
And then the meaning of Jesus
is completely lost, even the
next night.
So what's interesting, and I
guess quite bleak about it, is
that we really can't hold on to
our own experience, right?
We'd like to think that if we've
been through this, that
it's ours for good.
It's ours for life.
And it seems not
to be the case.
So let's move on now to
"Soldier's Home" and we know--
I'm just realizing the mic
is all the way down--
we know that this Krebs was a
soldier fighting in basically
all the famous battles in World
War I. And then he comes
home too late.
So by which time all the other
people have been back and
they've been telling stories
about war atrocities.
So nobody's listening
to him anymore.
And his mother is just worried
that he should find a job.
So this is the very near the
middle, just one line near the
middle of the story.
They're having breakfast. Krebs
is reading the papers
and worrying about his father
not wanting the paper to be
roughed up.
And then meanwhile, "Krebs
looked at the bacon fat
hardening on his plate."
And I think that is in some
sense to most graphic metaphor
that Hemingway has come up with,
a material emblem of our
own relation to our
own experience.
That this is the chemical
transformation.
It's so natural.
Last time we talked about the
naturalization of pain.
Childbirth is as natural
as rain.
And the pain that we inflict
on others is also
as natural as rain.
And here, for fresh experience
to go stale, it is as natural
as the bacon becoming
stale on your plate.
So that's just using a very
common object to talk about
the fate of emotions
across time.
And the fact that to go on
living is not cumulative.
There's a loss until the
longer you live.
I mean, this is a
terrible thing.
We like to think that some
things can be cumulative but
according to this paradigm, it's
almost as if the longer
you live, the more you
lose, actually.
And we know that Hemingway
actually chose to end his own
life, right?
So this is almost a kind of--
I mean he wasn't thinking about
suicide at that point,
at this early point--
but it's almost a justification
for suicide.
That you want to end it at the
moment of its greatest
intensity and greatest emotional
satisfaction.
You don't want to lose that.
So there's that, the bacon fat
hardening on his plate.
And at the very end of the
story, "Well, that was all
over now, anyway.
He would go over to the
schoolyard and watch Helen
play indoor basketball."
No detail is trivial.
No detail is random--
well, not always,
but quite often.
This is a very significant
detail in Hemingway.
And it's almost the kind of a
slightly larger view, moving
away from the bacon fat
on the plate to the
larger family situation.
Krebs was a very good soldier
during World War I. He's not a
very efficient player in
civilian life, right?
Helen is the player.
She's literally the
basketball player.
But she's also a player
in a bigger sense.
She's more consequential in life
than Krebs ever would be.
And it's the sadness of being
consequential, being only
consequentially important, very
good at what you're doing
in one context and being
terrible, not attended to, and
not listened to, being
completely on the sidelines
once you're put in a different
kind of situation.
So Krebs is on the sidelines,
a mere spectator, as Helen
plays both the indoor basketball
and also the game
of life that he's probably not
going to be very good at.
So obviously I think these two
stories, the connection
between them, very,
very tight.
They are in two different
settings.
But they really making exactly
the same point.
So let's move on now to a more
interesting kind of, not quite
so clear cut, between chapter
nine and "Mr. and Mrs.
Elliot." So chapter nine is in
many ways the Hemingway that
we're very familiar with, the
Hemingway in The Sun Also
Rises, the Hemingway who talks
about bull fights.
He also does it in the Death
in the Afternoon.
So this is the kind of
classic Hemingway.
Except there's a twist here.
"The first matador got the horn
through his sword hand
and the crowd hooted him.
The second matador slipped
and the bull caught
him through the belly.
He hung on to the horn with one
hand and held the other
tight against the place, and
the bull rammed him, wham,
against the wall and the horn
came out, and he lay in the
sand and then got up like crazy
drunk and tried to slug
the men carrying him away,
and yelled for his
sword but he fainted.
The kid came out and had to kill
five bulls, because you
can't have more than
three matadors."
This is the emotion, I think,
that is actually the dominant
emotion in In Our Time.
This isn't exactly tragedy.
It doesn't rise to the
level of tragedy.
But it's not exactly
funny, either.
And this is really the
combination of tragedy/comedy
that is so important
to Hemingway.
Nobody gets killed except for
the bull, five of them.
But that's supposed to happen.
There are two completely
incompetent matadors.
They're making a farce, really,
of the bull fight.
And meanwhile it's also farcical
in a different way
that you have to stick
by the rules.
Even though the first two
matadors are making a complete
mess of everything, you still
have to go by the rules.
So you can't have more
than three matadors.
And so one single person has
to kill five bulls because
that's the rule.
So this is the kind of a
combination we don't know
whether to laugh or to cry.
And I guess we laugh because
it's not worth crying over.
But it really is
not that funny.
And this is the nature of the
very complicated dark kind of
comedy that we get in Hemingway,
and that we'll be
getting in Fitzgerald and
Faulkner as well.
So this is really the
common ground.
Very interesting compounding
of genres.
Usually we're used to thinking
of tragedy and comedy as two
discrete genres, quite
separate, right?
But in American literature--
this really goes back to the
nineteenth century--
in American literature quite
often there's the mixing of
genres, with tragedy
being energized,
actually, by comedy.
And producing a really
interesting kind of
experimental genre.
So OK.
So keep that in mind it's
about bull fighting and
incompetent matadors.
And then the kid having
to clean up the mess.
So it would seem on the face of
it, it would seem that that
really could not have any
relation to "Mr. and Mrs.
Elliot," which has nothing
to do with bull fighting.
It's about a poet, or someone
who's trying to be a poet, and
his wife, and so forth.
But this very interesting
history behind this story.
And "Mr. and Mrs. Elliot," the
story, was first published in
The Little Review.
Last time we talked about how
a lot of the pieces came out
in little magazines, right?
So this is The Little Review,
1924/1925 edition.
And then it came out again,
in In Our Time, obviously,
Deliver Right edition, the
American edition, 1925.
And it turns out that Hemingway
actually has written
a very telling letter
to Horace Liveright.
You can see it here.
Actually, I think that if you go
to ClassesV2 to look at the
image online, you should be able
to zoom in and actually
look at all the words.
But anyway, this is the
transcript of one of the
paragraphs.
"As you will see I have revised
the Mr. and Mrs.
Elliot story and entirely
eliminated the obscene image.
It is a shame it had to be
changed, but as you say, it
would be a very silly play to
get the entire first book
suppressed for the sake
of the few funny
cracks in one story...
Jane Heap ran it in its original
form." This is The
Little Review--
editor of The Little Review.
"Jane Heap ran it in the
original form and did not get
into any trouble." OK.
So we're talking about a libel
suit it looks like.
That legal action could be
visited upon Hemingway because
of his story.
So what could be the cause
for this legal
action against Hemingway?
The title of the story
is suggestive, right?
Elliot is a very important
name in both American
literature and British
literature.
Very, very important name.
This is T.S. Eliot, obviously.
Known to Hemingway.
They were in the same
circles, both in
England and also in France.
And T.S. Eliot was one of the
most important poets,
twentieth century poets, best
known for the poem "The
Wasteland," would go on in 1948
to win the Nobel Prize.
So major poet.
And this is a picture of his
first wife, Vivienne.
And Eliot on the far right and
Vivienne is on the far left.
And it was a marriage that ended
in divorce, and with
Vivienne having lots and lots of
mental problems. So it was
a kind of very public
dissolution of the marriage.
Very painful, actually, when she
was clearly going crazy.
So Hemingway's story isn't
really about that.
But it's really making fun of
something that really didn't
end up being all that funny.
It was a kind of horrendous
episode in T.S. Eliot's life.
But the way that Hemingway
is talking about it
initially is this.
This is his version.
And, as you will see, he's
actually changed
the spelling, right?
T.S. Eliot just one "l." And so
just to remove the threat
of legal action for himself,
he's changed
the spelling of Elliot.
And this is a story
that he tells.
"Mrs. Elliot and the girl friend
now slept together in
the big medieval bed.
They had many a good
cry together.
In the evening they all sat at
dinner together in the garden
under a plane tree and the hot
evening wind blew and Elliot
drank white wine and Mrs. Elliot
and the girl friend
made conversation and they were
all quite happy." Once
again, this is the
happy ending in
quotation marks in Hemingway.
But you can really see why T.S.
Eliot would contemplate
legal action against Hemingway,
obviously.
The suggestion of a lesbian
relationship, not really--
there was nothing, actually, in
the actual life of Vivienne
Eliot to suggest that there
was a lesbian relation.
She did have an affair very soon
after she was married to
T.S. Eliot, but with a man,
Bertrand Russell, actually a
famous philosopher.
So this is complete fabrication
on the part of Hemingway.
But, I think, that this
actually, possibly something
else, that's mixed
into the story.
It's the lesbian relationship
that stops this from being a
tragedy, right?
It really would have been
quite tragic if the girl
friend had not been there.
But it's really this three
triangular relation that
enables Mr. Elliot to drink
white wine and to spend all
night writing poetry.
He doesn't especially want
to be in the same
room with his wife.
And Mrs. Elliot and the girl
friend have many a good cry
together in the big
medieval bed.
And they were all quite happy.
So Hemingway is really, in one
sense, thinking of the
historic T.S. Eliot and
Vivienne Eliot.
But I think that he was also
actually thinking of another
couple, very good friends of
his at one point, that he
talks about at great length in
A Moveable Feast. Another
iconic figure in American
literature Gertrude Stein, and
her companion, lifelong
companion,
actually, Alice B. Toklas.
That's Gertrude Stein on the
right and Alice on the left.
And Hemingway also makes fun of
them in A Moveable Feast.
But, actually, if you guys
have seen Woody Allen's
Midnight in Paris--
if you haven't seen it,
try to see it on DVD.
Gertrude Stein is very, very
important there as, really, a
mentor to Hemingway.
I'm sorry, we thought
of showing this,
but it's still running.
So we don't have it
on DVD to show it.
But in any case, if you see that
Woody Allen movie, you'll
see that Gertrude Stein was
crucial both to other young
writers, but also
to Hemingway.
And so a very long lasting--
this was actually a sustainable
relationship, the
lesbian relationship.
For life, really.
And happy as much as any
relationship can be happy.
Those two were very,
very happy.
So I think that what Hemingway
has done, actually, to produce
this tragedy/comedy is to
compound the very unhappy T.S.
Eliot marriage to Vivienne
with much happier
companionship between Gertrude
Stein and Alice B. Toklas.
And he really wasn't thinking of
libel from Gertrude Stein,
she is not mentioned by name.
But she could not not have
been on his mind.
So it's just a really
interesting kind of a capsule
summary, actually, of a lot of
American literature in there.
So I think that that's
really the connection
with chapter nine.
Not so much the subject
matter.
There's no bull fighting
in the story.
But the tragedy narrowly averted
turning into a comedy
or a farce, halfway between
comedy and farce.
That is the ultimate outcome
of that kind of unusual
arrangement.
But still doesn't rise to
the level of tragedy.
And that's the most important
point for Hemingway.
So let's move on now to
the next cluster.
And I should stop here for a
moment and talk a little bit
about the analytic structure
that we'll be using for the
next set of stories
and chapters.
But actually beginning with
chapter nine and "Mr. and Mrs.
Elliot," we are beginning to
see a kind of logic of
substitution.
So Gertrude Stein and Alice B.
Toklas' relationship taking
the place--
this relatively happy
relationship--
taking the place of the unhappy
historical relation
between Vivienne and T.S. Eliot,
so that Hemingway can
get to a place where
he wants to be.
And so taking the place,
substitution, is a good thing
in that chapter and
in that story.
We'll explore the meaning
of substitution
in the other clusters.
Sometimes it's good.
Sometimes it's not so good.
It's always kind of a mixture.
But on the whole, I would say
that Hemingway is much more
interested in comedy
than tragedy.
And here I'm going against
Aristotle and, in fact, a
whole tradition of Western
thinking about genres.
Tragedy is the high,
dignified--
very dignified--
genre, Greek tragedy.
And that's what really
Aristotle talks
about in the Poetics.
His attention is really
all given to tragedy.
Comedy gets about two lines
in the Poetics.
So I think that tragedy just
has a different kind of
centrality to the entire
Western canon.
But comedy, arguably, is
actually just as interesting
and just as complex.
So in the rest of the course,
we'll be thinking about the
ways in which comedy actually is
right next door to tragedy.
We have to rethink
the landscape.
Rather than thinking of these
two as being on opposite ends
of the spectrum, to think
about almost a kind of
emotional proximity between
tragedy and comedy.
Not because this is a natural
proximity, but because the
writers that we're looking at
they tend to have that really
kind of interesting thinking
and mixing of genres.
So in the next cluster, chapter
ten and "Cat in the
Rain," we'll first of all,
look at one kind of
substitution taking place
in chapter ten, the
horse and the picador.
And then the cat in the
"Cat in the Rain."
I should mention that there's
a difference between the
picador and the matador.
This is a distinction I didn't
know about it before I started
reading about Hemingway.
Is that the matador is the one
who actually kills the bull.
The picador's function is
to weaken the bull.
The picador never actually
kills the bull.
So it's always kind of the
three step ceremony.
The bull by the time he comes
out, the bull is weakened
already by various people
sticking knives into him.
And the picador tries to do a
major job of weakening the
bull, and then the matador
comes out and
actually kills the bull.
And the picador doesn't actually
come out on foot.
He's always on a horse.
And this we find out how
Hemingway feels about that
practice, about a picador coming
out on a horse and
fighting the bull.
"They whack-whacked the white
horse on the legs and he kneed
himself up.
The picador twisted the stirrups
straight and pulled
and hauled up into the saddle.
The horse's entrails hung down
in a blue bunch and swung
backward and forward as he began
to canter, the monos
whacking him on the back of
his legs with the rods."
It's a terrible thing.
Actually, this has been banned
in many Spanish cities because
it's just so incredibly cruel.
And here are two images of that
kind of substitution,
shameless use of the horse as
a shield against the bull.
And we can see the expressions,
they're used to it.
This is done all the time.
This is not exceptional
cowardice on
the part of the picador.
That's part of the game.
But still it's very
hard to take when
you're looking at it.
And to see the entrails actually
coming up right at
that moment.
And here's another image.
There are just countless
images.
All you have to do is to type in
"Picador's Horse" on Google
and you'll find all
these images.
So Hemingway, even though he's
a big aficionado of the
matador coming out-- and we'll
see his celebration of this
one-on-one battle between the
matador and the horse--
just finds this practice
utterly despicable.
I mean, this is really
substitution at its worst. And
so he's talking about this--
it's hard to wrap our minds
around this completely
ritualized practice.
And so that's what he talks
about in chapter ten.
And then in "Cat in the Rain,"
once again there's no thematic
continuity between chapter ten
and "Cat in the Rain," about a
young American couple
in a hotel.
Completely non-violent
setting.
And doesn't seem very
dramatic either.
In some sense, it seems as if
nothing happens in that story.
But there is a kind of
interesting way in which we
can read that story as a story
about substitution as well, in
the sense that the young
wife does have one
very emphatic desire.
"'Anyway, I want a cat,' she
said. 'I want a cat.
I want a cat now.
If I can't have long hair or any
fun, I can have a cat.'"
So the cat, obviously,
is shorthand for
something else, right?
She's actually looking at this
kitty in the rain, not trying
to hide from the rain
under the table, and
thinking of the cat.
And she says, OK, you know, if
I can't have anything else, I
can't have my own silver at
a table, I can't have new
clothes, I want a cat.
But even those things, eating at
a table with my own silver,
even that is probably
just a metaphor for
something else as well.
And so the wanting a cat, the
fact that it's such an
artificial and unpersuasive
substitution for something
that she doesn't have in her
life, suggests that there is
something, that this very
peaceful story does have
something in common with a
very violent episode in
chapter nine.
It really has to do with the
way we think about what is
adequate to what we could call a
good life or a good marriage
or a good anything.
Hemingway isn't really thinking,
especially this
story is about what constitutes
a good marriage,
or what is absent that would
make for a bad marriage.
But it really is thinking,
generally and abstractly,
about what counts as a good life
or what counts as being a
good player in a bullfight.
And coming out and using your
horse as a shield, that
doesn't count as merit
for Hemingway.
So in this case,
it's the wife.
We think about the
configuration.
She goes out in the rain, an
umbrella opens up behind her,
and it's a hotel maid
that opens up the
umbrella behind her.
She says, "I want a cat.
I want a cat." And, in fact,
I'll just read you the ending
of that story.
"Someone knocked"--
on page 94--
"Someone knocked at her door.
'Avante,' George said.
He looked up from his book.
In the doorway stood the maid.
She held a big tortoiseshell cat
pressed tight against her
and swung down against
her body.
'Excuse me,' she said.
'The padrone asked me to bring
this for the senora.'"
First of all, it's a very sly
substitution going on.
Because I don't think it's
actually the same cat.
This big tortoiseshell cat
probably isn't the same kitty
that she saw earlier
in the story.
So there is one almost
comical kind of a
substitution going on.
But the more important
substitution in the story,
other than just wanting the
cat to stand for something
else, is also that instead
of the husband being the
emotional support for the
wife, it is the hotel
apparatus that has substituted,
has stepped in
and is fulfilling
that function.
The hotel maid is the one who
opens the umbrella when the
wife steps out into the rain.
She wants a cat.
It's the hotel staff that
brings the cat.
So this is, for me, this is
one of the best and most
memorable portraits of what's
missing in a marriage that is
just done in a couple
of pages.
And done completely through
third parties, right?
So this is a story supposedly
about husband and wife and is
almost told completely through
third parties, through the
cat, through the hotel maid,
through the padrone.
And so it says something about
Hemingway's strategy as well.
And this is really something to
think about for all of the
writers, is how to frame
the story and how to
populate the story.
And the population of what is in
the foreground in the story
isn't necessarily the center.
I mean the house maid is front
and center in this story.
This story isn't really about
the hotel maid, but
nonetheless she is in the
foreground, as is the cat.
So what is this story about?
This is a good question
to ask.
Actually, this is another
question that is related to
writing papers.
Start out by thinking
what is this
particular paragraph about?
I mean, certain things are in
the foreground, but it could
be there's something much more
marginal could actually be the
real subject of that
paragraph.
So it's always a good analytic
strategy to--
um, gosh, never thought--
is it mine?
It's not mine, right?
[Referring to the ringing
of a cell phone.]
Yeah.
For some reason I
just thought--
Good.
That would be really a
big embarrassment.
But, in any case, so here's
a little act of
substitution, whatever.
But so far we've been talking
about the clustering of the
stories in the chapters.
Really, kind of going in a
bleak direction, right?
You know it's not the lack of
emotional satisfaction seems
to be the main point in
all of these stories.
That's really the kind of the
tragedy/comedy is the lack of
adequate emotional resolution.
There's just no emotional
resolution at the end of the
"Cat in the Rain." There's no
emotional resolution at the
end of "Soldier's Home." There's
maybe a little bit of
emotional resolution at the end
of "Mr. and Mrs. Elliot,"
but really not that great.
So the question is, is this
kind of a natural resting
place for Hemingway?
Is that the kind of emotional
landscape that he feels most
comfortable with?
And that would be
completely OK.
I think that this is a viable
way of writing.
And you can have great
literature resting on
precisely that very precarious
state of lack of emotional,
lack of full satisfaction,
lack of full resolution.
But I think that Hemingway,
actually, is a slightly
different kind of writer.
So he is quite unashamed of
going to a sometimes almost
embarrassing extreme in a sense
that you don't want to
show that this is really
what you believe in.
So it's embarrassing
in this sense.
But he's not especially
embarrassed about making it
very clear what he believes in
and what he finds satisfying.
I think that's really what makes
Hemingway what he is.
In many ways, very emphatic
about belief and about
emotional space that he would
affirm and celebrate.
So let's look at
chapter twelve.
This is the combination that
shows that side of Hemingway.
And it's not surprising, it's
back to bull fighting.
But this time it's not the
picador on his horse.
"When he started to kill it
was all in the same rush.
The bull looking at him straight
in front, hating...
The bull charged and
Villalta charged.
And just for a moment
they became one.
Villalta became one with the
bull and then it was over.
Villalta standing straight and
the red hilt of the sword
sticking out dully between
the bull's shoulders.
Villalta, his hand up at the
crowd, and the bull roaring
blood, looking straight at
Villalta and his legs caving."
So some of us would
find it gory.
I don't think that I would
be singing the
praises of bull fighting.
But just to think in terms of
what Hemingway is doing, for
him this is the truly sublime
and satisfying moment for both
the matador and for the bull.
Because the repeated line is
that they became one, right?
So they became one.
That is the supreme ideal
for Hemingway.
Instead of having this shield
of the horse shielding you
from the bull, you are in direct
contact with the bull.
And whatever you do, you do it
in utter lack of distance.
So this is the kind of
the close up, the
diminishment of distance.
And the two of them really
bonding so tightly that it
really becomes a kind
of a single unit.
And that this could
be a metaphor
for any kind of thing.
It can be a man and a bull, it
could be a man and a woman, it
can be two women, it can be you
and a project you become
fused with.
But for Hemingway, this kind of
complete lack of emotional
insulation, we've talked about
the question of insulation in
Indian camp, but the complete
lack of emotional insulation
between yourself, that it's
something that you feel
utterly passionate about: that
for Hemingway, is the place
that he really wants
to get to.
And all those times when he
doesn't get there, you can see
why it's a kind of frustrating
resting place.
And he wants us to be frustrated
when we can't get
beyond those places.
So this is kind of the classic
Hemingway epiphany of
achieving this union
with the bull that
you're going to kill.
And the fact you're going to
kill this creature, according
to him, doesn't really matter
because you've achieved that
union at that critical moment.
So this is--
we are not reading The Sun Also
Rises, but this is almost
a completely parallel moment
in The Sun Also Rises.
Pedro Romero killing the bull.
"The bull charged as
Romero charged.
Romero's left hand dropped the
mulata over the bull's muzzle
to blind him, his left shoulder
went forward between
the horns and the sword went in,
and for just an instant he
and the bull were one..."
So you can see that that word
one is of critical importance
to Hemingway.
Two entities becoming one.
Even though, at the moment of
death and killing, is still
important to achieve that
oneness with the world.
So I'm sure it's romanticizing
bull fighting, but it's
actually one of the rare public
demonstrations of that
happening.
Actually, it's very hard
if we think about this.
It's very hard to see two things
becoming one in public,
so bull fighting is actually one
of the rare instances when
everyone can be there
and watch.
So Hemingway probably was
looking at something like this
and it's really more like a
dance than actually the
killing of the bull.
You can see why he would
want to romanticize
something like that.
It's really completely
choreographed in such a way so
that the violence becomes
completely ritualized and we
almost don't see the blood.
There's no blood
in this moment.
So anyway, so for Hemingway,
a completely unembarrassed
desire to get to this state,
he and the bull were one.
So let's move on now.
And I have to say I actually
like the "Big Two-Hearted
River" much more than the bull
fighting scenes in Hemingway.
This is a great story.
In many ways a rewrite
two-part story.
A rewrite of Krebs coming
home, right?
So this is also a
soldier's home.
He's not among his family.
But he is on this trip through
a country that is not really
disclosed to us.
A landscape we don't really
know where it is.
We don't know where he's going
or why he's on that trip.
But it's a fishing trip.
And this is what happens at the
moment when Nick catches--
Nick, this is the same Nick
that we see grown up.
The young Nick in "Indian Camp"
and "The Doctor's and
Doctor's Wife." Now he's a full
grown man and obviously
having been in war.
But coming back and going
through what appears to be a
healing process for
Hemingway, right?
So "Soldier's Home" is about
a non-healing of Krebs.
The trauma of war and
the trauma of
being completely marginal.
And being sidelined.
All of those things would
just keep hurting him.
In the case of "Big Two-Hearted
River," it's a
rewrite of that and it's a very
different outcome coming
out from that story.
And it has to do actually
with similar
dynamics to the bull fighting.
"Nick cleaned them, slitting
the trout.
Nick cleaned them, slitting them
from the vent to the tip
of the jaw.
All the insides and the
gills and the tongue
came out in one piece.
They were both males; long
gray-white strips of milt,
smooth and clean.
All the insides clean and
compact, coming out all
together."
So this is just as emotionally
satisfying as the
bullfighting.
Not in the sense that we don't
have to choreograph a moment
quite as dramatic and beautiful
as in the bullfight.
But to be able to expand the
ritual of dying in one piece
to the trout.
We do have to kill the trout
unless we're going to go
without any kind of
animal protein.
So the trout is being killed,
but the way, the manner of
killing is everything.
That there should be no
degradation in death.
That actually the measure of
a good life is first your
ability to offer a good
death to someone else.
We do this all the time.
It makes all the difference in
the world whether we kill
brutally or whether we kill
ceremoniously with full
respect for what we kill.
And it also makes all the
difference in the world if you
die a good death.
There's really no other
conclusion.
So it has to be completely
clean and satisfying.
Both to the creature who is
going through it and to the
person who is performing
that operation.
So this actually, as far as I
can see, Hemingway is actually
a very affirmative writer at
the end of In Our Time in a
sense that he's also revising
his own story.
He doesn't get to where he wants
to be in Krebs story in
"Soldier's Home," he comes
back and tells the
story one more time.
And this time he gets to
where he wants to be.
So, say goodbye to Hemingway,
now we move on to Fitzgerald
and The Great Gatsby
on Tuesday.